but here's a guy right here who's got
some strong information
you can tell out of the blue because it
is whatever time of year it is right now
which is i think
summer and there is a christmas tree
he's too lazy to take in the background
yeah and now he's already passed that uh
that senate that middle
you might as well leave it up and
theo what's up got a king understanding
for you gang bro
got that billy conforto shirt on r.i.p
uh kinder stinget
colonoscopies uh myself i have
ulcerative colitis which is an irritable
bowel disease so i've had like
seven colonoscopies in my life wow
they're not too bad
you know they slide you some drugs uh
your pass out
they're all up in your holes uh i like
to refer to it as that bill
colinas cosby get what i'm saying um
just want to say i love you guys i've
been sick actually with this disease the
last couple years
i've been restricted to being at home a
lot uh your podcast really helps
keeps my spirits up everybody down there
at the king and the sting fam
you guys are making me laugh every week
uh or if i'm real sad i'll pull like a
theo and listen to some bishop gun turn
on some shine or i'll pull up brendan
and like just get punched in the head
and forget
stuff like that amen bro love you guys
hope you come through st
louis soon uh gang gang swollen colony
is that different than what your sister
does oh yeah uh colonoscopy they just
stick a camera up there my sister washes
it out
oh wow
look that's that andy do frame what his
sister does
they should have a special package
called that andy dufresne
you know yeah where they washed two
dudes out of your butt in and out
they said it would take 600 years this
is my morgan freeman impersonation and
i'll do it for you guys because
half you guys are pieces of [ __ ]
it's your only brendan impression
you can't let me do it i've heard it
though
they said it would take a minute 600
years to get out of the sea of prison
but andy dufresne did it in less than
20.
that's him crawling through some [ __ ]
pretty good huh
i actually got to give you props on that
one thank you man i appreciate that
uh yeah that's a tough time bro this is
a tough time
and this before they had the camera they
would send a guy in there right there
that's that video
um yeah thanks for the shout out man and
yeah i think put all the christmas trees
up man if you got to keep your spirits
up
yeah if that makes you happy leave them
up dog yeah do put up a halloween you
know
go door to door and ask for candy do
whatever you got to do man
cake all day doug yeah uh
what was this guy asking about do you
understand
i'll take one i'm not doing two though
if you want to
check it out i guess i'm gonna do it you
know but here
brendan's the kind of guy that would get
a colonoscopy by laying on his back and
holding his legs open
like a baby i would do it on my back and
you do it on all fours
dude all fours is the way to do it bro i
don't think so dude
what i think i think you're passed out
right and they just flip you over
dude well i'm passing out on all fours
dog you know what i'm saying like a
champion
yeah dude like a baby with his butt now
why'd he leave a thong
on
[Laughter]
dude i think you got to go if i'm going
colonoscopy
i guess man i mean if you need them do
it dog
are they good to do huh they say they
are but they say a lot of stuff man it's
basically vaccine for your butt
so if you want to you know if you're i'm
more of an anti-vaxxer i think
i think you know i haven't read up on it
but it seems fun
dude how do you know if you need one
though you know
if you feel like it does your butt feel
kind of risky
i don't know if it's much of the butt
more so the the hole
you ever had a hemorrhoid no have you
had one
i think i did have one yeah that's
that's not you've had one oh yeah
wow how'd you get it
lifting heavy weights and being
overweight
you can get it just from being
overweight oh wow if you're overweight
and you lift real heavy weight like
there's a lot of strain like i was
dead lifting or squatting in college i
just remember my [ __ ]
itch like never before and i keep
itching it and just got worse worse and
worse
and the next thing you know you got this
grape size
hemorrhoid [ __ ] no it was awful
you're disgusting
dude that's life bro that ain't life
dude
i've been alive and that's not happened
to you and then some people have they
have to tie it off with a rubber band
and surgically remove them no
first of all the person that just puts
cream on it is a pervert
okay that's what you gotta do dude if
something's hanging out of my buttocks
and i'm putting cream on it i know
i'm a freak bro you're a freak huh
second of all yeah you gotta cut that
thing off dude i'd have a couple beers
and cut that [ __ ] off
you know set up a couple of mirrors in
your room to be able to do it and
you know in it you know was it bad to
use the restroom
awful ah nick you've never had a
hemorrhoid
out of anybody why why
i don't know dude i had appendicitis
once and before they found it they stuck
their fingers up my butt it wasn't a
full colonoscopy but
that felt weird yeah yeah no hemorrhoids
though i don't even know if you needed
to tell us that sorry
yeah i had nothing to do with handbrake
i was trying to yes and no you're right
that's a good call you're right you're
right you're right good good job it's
good
you're not in the ass play well here's
the thing man
is if you have i think i don't know if i
where i'm from i think if you have bad
shrimp you can get them
you know that's fair so it's more of
what your diet is
a lot of pregnant girls get them really
yeah yeah when the one because
when they're pushing with the baby then
the hemorrhoids go oh my god they have
the
strength yeah
[Music]
is